what steps have you taken to find out
that I I ran it on my own machine
actually that's not quite true I ran it
on a virtual machine so I installed a
virtual XP machine unpatch from this
current patch it wasn't connecting the
Internet I downloaded the wanna cry XE
and lanit and my files were encrypted
and it popped up the warning message
this isn't something to try I was right
I know I would advise against it right
so nothing there's nothing inherently
scary about the software in the sense
that if it's not connected to the net it
won't propagate and if you don't have
anything valuable in your machine you
aren't going to lose any files but on
the other hand I'm not running it here
on a university network because I don't
want to be the first person the
institution's nothing so you know just
on the off-chance right so let's not
let's not open that door so when we
start on this myth what's it called so I
call it one a Decrypter or one a
sure you wanna cry wanna cry wanna clip
to one decrypter when I decrypted to as
far as I can tell the source code has
one equip two in it a lot of people
shorten this to wanna cry and there is
sort of WNC are why extension but it
uses for its encrypted files which are
which kind of spells want to cry so yeah
okay so I don't know I'm calling it one
equip sir but I might just not mention
it by name again because we all know
what we're talking about
it's ransomware right so ransomware is
any trojan or worm or virus that in
essence encrypts your files and then
tries to charge you money to reverse
that process without giving them too
much credit but obvious reason it's a
fairly smart way of performing crime
because if the antivirus is not
immediately on the ball then the damage
is already done
and a lot of the time you won't get the
key back unless you pay and so you have
to vend either restore from backup which
a lot of people don't have and or you
have to accept that your files are gone
or you have to pay and so that it's no
surprise but sort of the biggest stuff
in the news recently in terms of attacks
have been ransomware because of the
immediate impact they have on standard
users there are lots and lots of other
kinds of malware you know banking for
malware and key loggers and things and
botnet
code which is also a really big problem
but perhaps disease less news because it
doesn't attack the NHS for those of you
but they don't live in England you might
you know not know huge amount about the
NHS if your national health service is
our taxpayer-funded health service right
so we all pay taxes and then those taxes
contribute to a health service and we
all get health care perhaps we all need
to calm the rhetoric down slightly
you know the NHS itself is not under
attack the nice thing for the media is
if you if you can have your headline say
attack on the Health Service then you're
going to get a lot of hit right so
that's the first thing that's happened
and in fact actually only a small subset
of health care machines have been taken
down by this ransomware and a lot of
it's been precautionary so bring down
the server just on the off chance it
gets it until we can be sure that
nothing on the same network has the has
the Trojan or the worm on it so yeah so
it's it's a big deal and it's infected a
lot of machines but there were a lot of
other big ransom wares out there right
quick the wall would have made millions
of développé of dollars to its
developers for example so this isn't the
only one it's not the first and
regrettably probably won't be the last
let's talk about a bit about what
happens right so one Friday various
machines started being affected by this
now the exact nature of the initial
infection I don't think is known right
now it might be by the time this video
goes out right so maybe I'll be out of
date already but probably emails right
so which makes it essentially a trojan
because an email goes out with a spear
phishing attack or a phishing attack
that sort of says you should click this
for whatever reason and tricks a user
into doing it now you don't need to
trick many users to get return on your
investment in some sense because once
they get infected that's a lot of money
this sudden Trojan Orbis worm is a
little bit unusual in that it actually
have carried a self-replicating payload
most ransomware doesn't do this most
ransomware
the idea is basically to email as many
people as possible some of them some
small subset of them will be tricked
into clicking it they will be the ones
that hopefully pay the ransom that's
there at the logic of it this one uses
an exploit that was first found by the
NSA and exploit windows so this one
ability has existed in Windows for quite
a while I mean it's exists in Windows XP
that was around in 2001 and so on and it
seems we've disappeared
sometime around windows 10 right so it
was actually March and we don't know if
I think that we've got a bit it doesn't
already exist in Windows 10 so so it's
hatched in March unit in Windows 7 yes
and for any for any operating system
that might self is currently actively
rolling out patches for which is to say
Windows 7 I don't think we did this to
anymore there are plenty of copies of
windows right there Longley that still
have their own ability now this is a
vulnerability in the SMB protocol which
is usually used for file sharing across
networks very common because you imagine
large organizations like to share files
from a central server to all that
smaller machines rather than having
everyone store all the files all the
time so what happens when this worm
lands is that so this worm will start
with an email probably or some will
actually deliver it by USB that seems
less likely but but probably an email
you only need one person on the network
to click on it and they get them and
somewhere and then it starts to sniff
out on port 445 for other unpatched
installations of so this is a directed
exploit which will be able to run this
same code on target machine and then
they spread and so on that's why it
spread so quickly
Patong ability was discovered by the NSA
quite a while ago five or six years ago
we think we don't know exactly because
they don't tell us and rather than tell
Microsoft about this exploit they
decided to sit on it with the with the
idea that they could then use it in
their own exploit so their exploit kit
became eternal blue that's the code name
for this particular exploit and in some
sense no more was heard about it right
from a for a while it probably got used
by the government agencies to perform
their characters and tasks and so on
until they were themselves hacked by
another group called the shadow brokers
who decided to try and sell some of
these tools and then just release them
on the Internet so Microsoft practiced
on ability in March and then in April
the shadow brokers released eternal blue
the code for it onto the net it was only
a matter of time before someone put this
onto a self-replicating piece of
ransomware
right because and the quicker you do it
the more people who are still unpatched
that you get right and then damage your
shoes the key difference really with
this from this
and somewhere to the previous ransomware
that we've seen is the fact that it can
self propagate right sometimes these
things get built into self-replicating
programs but in this one this eternal
blue exploit essentially means that your
machine if it's not patched you don't
have to click yes like another machine
will upload the payload to it and it
will run it no questions asked and it
might if you're running a server which
has shadow volume copies and things and
a backup backup and restore it might ask
you for a yes or no response later in
the process but a bit late you know
after a lot of things already been
encrypted so most Trojans if you're very
vigilant about running email attachments
you'll never get them because you just
see how it's a Trojan or it's a I don't
want to go to that website it looks
malicious and so you don't you don't get
them even if you don't have antivirus
but if you haven't got this update you
can still get it despite the fact that
you haven't done anything apart from
perhaps be a bit lazy about you updates
sometime over the weekend obviously lots
of researchers are looking into it into
this not so I was looking into it and
running it purely for interest right you
know I don't I'm not working any tools
to get rid of it or anything anything
clever but there are lot of researchers
of what they will do is they will run
this in a virtual machine or in a
special sort of sandbox where it's
isolated find out what it does and try
and work out how they could stop it try
and work out how they could take the
role of a command and control server for
example and tell it just to stop or
something like this now a researcher
malware tech who whose blog is really
interesting and will link to it in the
bottom
they basically stumbled across the kill
switch for this because they were
looking at what it did and it polled
this it checked for the existence of
this unregistered Internet address so it
basically said it did a DNS lookup and
said who is this who's got this Internet
address and no one had it so their first
responsible as well if we register that
Internet address we then get
communication from all the installations
of this and we can sort of track how
many people have got this is it's
interesting from a research point of
view we can see how it's spread but in
fact will actually happen within the
code was if it if this web address
existed
it just stopped running their hypothesis
is that it's doing a kind of Volkswagen
emissions situation where it realizes
it's running in some kind of lab
environment and shuts down but basically
as soon as they registered this web
address all future installations of
Warnock richter want a decrypter
shutdown immediately upon starting up
which was obviously quite good news
so inadvertently they saved a lot of
people a lot of time and effort and
maybe money that isn't the end to this
story an inconceivably people have seen
this out yeah so there's been multiple
versions of this with tweak settings
innocent where they probably remove I
think they potentially just tried to hex
edit out the kill switch and run it
again and and yes that's that's not
unexpected now I take said this is going
to come it's very is to be expected
because the code is not difficult to
change to avoid the whole kill switch
right obviously their their attempt at
circumventing some of the researchers
abilities has failed and it
inadvertently reduced the impact of the
virus or the worm so they'll just
release it again and I'll send out
another huge bunch of emails now
hopefully people are now aware this
exists and people are aggressively
updating their systems and it will have
this impact but some people are bound to
get it again I think China is being hit
pretty hard today is going through China
at the moment so it tends to sort of hit
networks and spread about until people
sort of realize what's going on and put
a stop to it
not everyone has got this I haven't got
it right you haven't got it no one are
not English far as we know we've got it
and that's because these SMB ports are
blocks internally by our firewall words
are coming in their blocks so you then
an infected NHS machine can't target a
university of not in computer because
the portal blocks many of the networks
that have been compromised and networks
where a machine inside the network has
been compromised and it's spread around
the in terms of the network via majority
of ransomware is a Trojan in the sense
of it it masquerades as something else
and appears on your computer usually for
an email attachment this one is both the
Trojan in that sense because that
probably probably what happened here but
it's also a worm in the sense that it
can propagate out itself using this
exploit so this eternal blue exploit
already exists and was known to the NSA
for some time it's already been patched
but a lot of people aren't installing
updates as vigorously as they should be
and also mics will start routinely
putting out updates for Windows XP so
anyone running Windows XP and also now
when the Vista and so on we won't have
that update because it does not what
happens now in Australia in a sort of
unusual move Microsoft has pushed an
update to XP because of this severity of
this that's unusual
if you're running XP the first thing you
should do is turn off your machine
because you've got no business running
XP but you aren't going to get many
updates because that's not what
Microsoft's are doing this is the like
I'm Nicola no remotes parts room is
exactly like that in fact a good analogy
I think is people have laid remarks off
of this there's a lot of blame to go
around
Microsoft share some of the blame but in
some ways what's happened is we're all
driving around in 1940 Fords and then
when we have an accident we're
complaining that the airbag didn't go
off when an airbag in the 1940s for
that's why like so unless you take it
into the garage and have one installed
you know it's that kind of principle so
yes Microsoft's loads an operating
system with this bug in my all operating
systems had buttons all software has
bugs in they patched it quickly and they
found it they patch it in March is not
in Windows 10 anyway and they've
aggressively put out patches for a
legacy operating system to try and
combat it so they have at least trying
to take all the steps they can to solve
this the problem is that organized a big
organizations like the NHS have legacy
software let's say that drivers for
scanners and you know MRI machines and
so on but maybe they bought 10 20 years
ago that are still running XP because
the software is compatible with modern
versions of Windows that's a whole whole
political issue that I don't you know I
don't know I don't have all the answers
for so in the CIA leaks a few months ago
showed that the CIA also has a sort of
to say a back catalogue of exploits that
they keep a whole lot so the NSA and the
CIA will disclose some problems they
find but if they find a bug a normal
security researcher will privately
disclose it to the company for them to
release a patch and then will publicize
it later partly for a sort of media
purposes and partly because
encourages people to install the update
the NSA and other government agencies
don't operate this policy all the time
because they view some of these exports
is useful for combating terrorism and
other criminal activity now that may be
may or may not be the case but what's
happened in this case is they've allowed
themselves to be hacked by another group
who has had no ethical concerns and just
releasing all this so this actually goes
neatly back to our end-to-end encryption
talk because I said that what you're
doing with with introducing a backdoor
is introducing a very big point of
failure
well back exactly what's happened here
right the NSA didn't tell anyone about
this because they felt they could
privately use it for the good of their
country and that may have been the case
but it's not the case anymore because
someone's hacked them and released it so
that's a huge problem when that sort of
thing happens so there are already
people who are we Microsoft themselves
in their blog have mentioned it already
and Ross Anderson mentions it in his
blog and will link both of those in the
bottom that you know you can't they
can't wipe the hands of this entirely
they can say well we're you know we're
doing this to counterterrorism but in
some ways it is also their fault because
it was their export it's been used the
headlines today all saying it's a
wake-up call well really people like
Ross Anderson and other security experts
have been saying this for years like
this isn't the first time we've noticed
that old machines are vulnerable to
attack so yeah maybe it's a wake-up call
but people need to be aggressively
installing the latest operating systems
and updating as far as I know you can't
turn off updates in Windows 10 and that
strikes me as quite a good idea because
people will turn them off god I don't
want it to reset right now I'll turn it
off and I'll resume it later and that's
when they get hit by a piece of
ransomware emergency braking because so
in the future the robe or chauffeur
which will actually drive you work while
you're sitting there acting some code
and so you then got the technical
problems and the business problems of
how do you produce software upgrades
which married